we may not be as impressive as the ruler
of a kingdom or anything but this week's
wrecks still qualify as pretty great
along with the return of a popular
anti-historical series we've got a movie
about your favorite smartphone not made
by Apple the return of a star-studded
book club an inspiring story from an
all-time great and an extra wreck for
Asian American Pacific Islander month
Rotten Tomatoes is taking you all out
for Yummy affordable Burger sliders
figuratively of course oh on this week's
what to watch but I will be the leader I
promised myself I would be letting all
pursue their happiness as they see fit
that's a pretty good description of
Anarchy ascending into its third season
is the hit Hulu series The Great this
satire described by Hulu as
anti-historical has two certified fresh
Seasons under its corset including
season two at a hundred percent on the
Tomato Meter that's reason one and I
guess 1A to get in on season three while
we're at it reasons 2 and 2A would have
to be the show's two Emmy nominated
Stars L Fanning and Nicholas halt who
play married couple Catherine the Great
and Emperor Peter III and speaking of
Fanning she teased at a deadline event
earlier this year that season three will
see the characters working on their
marriage with counseling and perhaps
even a marriage witch marriage yeah I
read that right Howlin is going to be
really interesting this year the guys
I know how to Market it and I know who
we can sell it to but I want 50 of the
company and I've got to be CEO I don't
know who you think you are but deal
are you joking dialing up a spot in
theaters this week is the biopic
blackberry and as you might be hoping
when you see the title yes this cheeky
dramedy does tell the unbelievable story
of the Blackberry considered the world's
first smartphone AKA that one thing
everybody had before they got an iPhone
and if you haven't already got enough to
check a forgotten drawer for your old
Blackberry it's worth noting that this
film was adapted from a popular book so
you know there were plenty of juicy
details to choose from and it stars the
always entertaining Jay Baruchel and
Glenn Howerton with Carrie Elway's in a
supporting role on top of all that Berry
goodness this Film Festival darling has
already certified fresh on the command
meter with a critics consensus saying
with intelligence as sharp as its humor
Blackberry takes a terrifically
entertaining look at the rise and fall
of a generation defining Gadget we're
best friends for 50 years and you
married marriage my solo act is finally
coming to a close you're the bravest
person I know the only question is how
will we mess this all up I can't a way
to find out getting together in theaters
once again is book club the next chapter
and the first reason to check out this
sequel to 2018's book club is that it
once again features the same loaded cast
with Jane Fonda Diane Keaton Candice
Bergen and Mary steenbergen only this
time we get to enjoy them in a different
environment as they are taking their
little book club on the road to Italy
where plenty of drama is on Court and
while the first book club is just over
the 50 mark on the Tomato Meter it ended
up being a box office success no doubt
because a bunch of real book clubs met
up and went well time to do it again no
one outside of my family knew there was
only one reason I took these bills to
hide
but all those years of hiding was
shaking me away streaming on Apple TV
plus is the biodoc still a Michael J fox
movie now because the fact that Michael
J fox is just flat out awesome and
inspiring this film takes the unique
approach of pulling in archival
documentary and scripted elements to
tell Fox's story and that includes
giving us major access to his family and
personal life and with a fresh tomato
meter score hovering just under a
hundred percent it's obvious this one
has had an impact on critics in fact the
critics consensus calls this one
poignant and profound offering a
captivating inside look at the life and
career of a beloved Entertainer what
happened to the White Castle
what there used to be a White Castle
right here in this location where is it
I hate to be the bear bad news guys but
Burger Shack they bought this location
about four years ago and finally how
about chilling at home and pulling up
the classic comedy Harold and Kumar Go
to White Castle on Voodoo and you may be
wondering why we picked this movie
especially considering that 420 has
already passed but there's actually two
to celebrate Asian American Pacific
Islander month plus the fresh gem turns
19 this year yup you're totally getting
old which means it falls under our rt25
celebration as we look back fondly on 25
years of rotten tomatoes so yeah I guess
we're having a double party which I'm
sure Harold and Kumar would definitely
approve of and don't forget Voodoo has
this and a ton of other aapi
month-themed titles to choose from
all right we did it five great wrecks to
cover all your bases this week you're
welcome be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
you did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and
seriously check out the new rt25 page
where we're celebrating 25 years of
Rotten Tomatoes that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay fresh
foreign
[Music]